how do you have time to study about the
government when you're too busy trying
to [ __ ] feed your family so it's like
you're too busy being your family
[Music]
all right so the San Francisco Chronicle
they used a machine learning to sort
through 2.3 million property records in
the area of SF and the results showed
that majority of the Bay Area is owned
by 12 Mega landlords I wouldn't be
surprised because a lot of properties
what people don't know is owned by like
big companies like [ __ ] BlackRock
Blackstone is that something that's
super common
it is now you know because they got the
money to buy up everything you remember
that one period where like even Zilla
was buying up homes yeah so it would be
like oh your realtor can't sell it I'll
buy it for you it seemed like oh [ __ ] is
Zillow moving into a market where
they're just gonna start buying up all
the real estate too
um I was just gonna say the gov is the
government in on that too but do they
have like government uh specific shells
that are like Kickbacks or subsidies is
that just at like the mortgage-backed
Securities whole thing with like the fed
and whatnot I think the the politicians
who have control over uh you know zoning
they get they're the ones getting all
the Kickbacks because I think about
certain zones couldn't happen unless
they made it happen they're getting that
nickel off the vending machine man
vehicle off the vending machine that
[ __ ] hockey coach dude corrupt
principles everywhere the the government
if you consider like the military and
all these things they own a lot of land
like they're they're if you if you add
them in the list they're one of the
biggest land owners of private land or
not private but like let's say there's a
Zone like there's a military base that
would technically be government owned so
so you said something that kind of
sparked a little bit in my my curiosity
right now uh Brian looked at you and
said is that comment you're like it is
now so that means like not long ago most
homeowners were really home owners like
individuals right maybe like two
generations ago a generation ago
definitely like I'm guessing in like the
50s and before that if you bought a home
you probably bought at home like you own
the home whatever right um what does
that mean moving forward like obviously
in the near future these these 12 Mega
landlords or or even like you know
100 years from now even less own more
like what is that actually going to do
to our
Society yeah what does that mean uh
we're gonna turn into a renter renting
Nation you will own nothing and rent
everything and be okay with it in the
Sun Belt
not even American companies they allow
two Canadian hedge funds to buy up
pretty much the Sun Belt so they're
buying up these homes where's the Sun
Belt at it's like Georgia that that East
Coast Area that Georgia I think the
Caroline is right there so you know when
Millennials graduate that's where
they're migrating because it's close to
the beach close to you know closer to
the coast but it's affordable so before
they even get there these hedge funds
are coming in buying up all these new
properties and properties and renting it
out to them making it almost impossible
for them to buy a house so they'd rather
just rent these nice or newer homes in
on in the Sun Belt so think about this
it's the government that allowed it so
you gotta think about anytime
something happens there's got to be a
shot caller she's been to jail before
there's always a shock hauler and things
don't happen in the yard unless the shot
car lets it happen so you think and it's
so funny when they just blame
corporations you're greedy corporations
but who's allowing the corporations to
come in right so is the move to just buy
something as quickly as possible before
it becomes a rendered Nation or yeah I
think so you think about so Home
Building just picked up speed but not on
single family homes on apartments or
multi-units because it's too expensive
to build a home and sell it to a
consumer right now because interest
rates are so high so they're still
building but they're building more
Apartments it's pretty much this country
is becoming a subscription country so
they want you to be tied to the T and
keep you know are there any countries
that are already like that and we can
see what America is turning into
not that I know of off top of my head
you know I think Canada is probably the
worst because Canada's you know things
are so expensive in Canada you can only
rent
and that's why Canada like think about
they start off with
um free health insurance right everyone
gets health insurance now you're used to
that and then they're going to create
another layer and then another layer so
like okay it's too expensive at least
we'll make sure they're all housing but
you have to pay x amount well you can't
afford health insurance here's free
health insurance for everybody you know
so we're a netflix-ass country overall
dude yeah yeah it's turned that way I'm
going to tell you guys about some of
those uh companies that own the
properties and they all have like these
interesting little characteristics like
[ __ ] Oscar Meyer [ __ ] [ __ ] own
like 30 homes but they also create they
they do like genocide in another name
there's no there's like one strange
feature about all of them one of them is
called Veritas Investments and um so
like when they look up the names of like
who's operating these apartments Veritas
Investments doesn't even appear
yet they do run it and in a weird way
it's like they uh they they say they
work with investors to buy rentals and
manage tenants but it won't save Veritas
Investments however they'll be llc's
that have invested with Veritas to own
these apartments and those LLCs are
registered under the name of the CEO of
veritas so it's not actually I don't
know what that workaround achieves uh
not a shell but like a way to protect
legally yeah and it's and it's the CEO
and his family members that are
registered to those llc's each uh it's
pretty much they're diluting the taxes
because if you have you know money comes
in if you make x amount of money instead
of you paying taxes on let's say 100
million bucks all right they spread it
out so everyone's tax brackets lower so
you pay less taxes so that's one thing
reason why they do it and the second
reason is for uh if someone gets hurt
you're suing the corporation which it's
just a shell and then
yeah so you can still sue the individual
but it won't attack like the parent
company Veritas or something like that
because they're separate
why they make llc's is for each thing
that you own like a complex or a home
they own it's owned by one LLC and that
gets
that's protecting the the you're
assuming the LLC you're not suing the
person in general so let's say you know
you fall in this building you're suing
the person who owns this building only
and the building's under an LLC because
you can't sue that person directly
because you fell into this building
because BlackRock owns this place now
oh wow so there's another guy named
Michael Marr and this dude is Infamous
he's one of the East Bay's largest
private landlords and then this dude's
had this dude has had some problems with
the FBI because he has office rated in
2011.
um he conspired with a bunch of other
bidders to not go into a bidding war
when uh properties were up for auction
so him and a whole network of people
would just one guy would bid for it and
no one would fight him so everyone got
cheap ass land so that's just called
friendship in my opinion
yeah
he was found guilty of friendship homies
that's called taking turns remember I
paid for dim sum last time guys
I kind of agree that does sound kind of
cool it's like it's like if all of us
were like hey today
um it's your turn to get the apartment
okay yeah I mean that's unionizing in a
way right like a Clifford the Big Red
Dog book could be based on that you know
that's teamwork dude it's like now you
buy a home for cheaper now you buy homes
cheap everyone's happy man yeah the
thing is they all kept their word and
and they no one fought against each
other so I'm like that's really friendly
yeah is that illegal
I think that's illegal I think uh you
know it depends how you Corner the
market I think um you know business is
business I see like you know like my
buddies they would buy the sensors back
then and they would buy the building and
they would just you know make things so
expensive to force out the other
dispensaries and they would do to force
them out of the whole area you know
Garden Grove and then they would take
ownership of it and then it got it so
cheap they just forced people out wow
they would buy their buildings increase
the rent or they would make their
products so cheap that the you know the
the shops there can't compete and then
they'd Force then they'd sell buy the
product back from those guys and then
kick them out and then end up owning
that corner they would own more corners
that way so they would like buy that
person's business as they move out so
they would keep the business in that
spot but it's under new ownership they
were just like slowly monopolize the
entire thing yeah and their clients were
still there because think about if you
go there to buy your you know your your
marijuana
still there like it's not like it it
went anywhere yeah it's part of your
route yeah like you're just gonna keep
going right so you they buy the building
they would uh make their stuff as cheap
as possible dirt cheap and they would
race start raising rent slowly and then
think about you can't sell weed but your
rent keeps going up you eventually have
to bounce all right okay we'll help you
out whatever you have in there we'll buy
that 50 off so you can at least walk
away yeah
when you liquidate they just like
consume like take all but when these
guys do it it's not against yeah when
these guys do it's not Babble and you
know yeah yeah right oh dang so the
third one they talk about is called
Greystar real estate Partners oh we know
great stuff you know Greystar okay start
owns my building oh wow yeah well they
uh they they've been sued by the feds
over 200 times in the past 26 years
yeah great great Stars International so
they're all over the world they own
almost
um in the US 750 000 multi-family units
wow and uh seven what the [ __ ] that's
750 000 Apartments
the residents dude that's crazy they
have a whole country worth of residence
and they're known like as the coldest
group like they're the like the they're
Savage the like the slum Lords of the
world well not slumlords but they'll do
moves that are like pretty [ __ ]
ballsy like they uh they became famous
when they demolished a 216 unit rent
controlled complex in Silicon Valley
yeah yeah to build one bedroom units
starting at 32.99 per month
well I mean it is Silicon Valley and
that's kind of what the whole like uh
that brings us back to like these 12
Mega landlords in the Bay Area is that
people foresaw the Silicon Valley thing
and capitalized on it so you know when
you're a group with a lot of money and
privileged information you can afford to
make a move this big yeah sure so it
sounds like what
um I guess what's like not under
scrutiny but what makes it look bad is
that for the sake of business they're
crushing the affordability of common
folks right because they're technically
not doing anything wrong by buying like
a big ass unit tearing it all down but
then now the the demographic here didn't
really change and all of a sudden
they're all luxury apartments yeah yeah
yeah and that's kind of the I think the
gripe is a historically SF used to be
anti-establishment needs to be more
Progressive yeah and now like that
thinking is sort of gone because it's
being replaced and and that identity is
now like forgotten last because the
stupid ass [ __ ] workers that are
at these protests right they're [ __ ]
like [ __ ] protesting with their
posters The Whole World's changing
behind them and they don't know you're
like [ __ ] you need to go change
[ __ ] back there but like change the laws
change in the literally an entire
[ __ ] housing project gets crushed
gets [ __ ] erected now it's luxury
homes and to like change the laws and
turn around they're like what the [ __ ]
happened my duh
dude that's honestly that's the best way
you can put it yeah same speed time
lapse dude I think uh what Joe said
earlier I think the the power of unity
even though it's either evil or good if
you you have a group of people that can
agree on something that the meeting room
with same like mine all right same like
people meet in the room they agree on
something they can do anything that's
why I feel like really bad about
um you know people out there protesting
because like they don't know how to
fight effectively they think let's March
and spread awareness that's gonna reduce
prices or whatever that's not like you
gotta fight effectively through
government through being business savvy
through Finance through hitting
businesses that you don't agree with or
whatever like and then it's just kind of
sad because like they'll they'll they'll
post [ __ ] on Twitter or whatever
thinking that that's doing something or
like they'll go out play a [ __ ]
they'll hit their back drums and [ __ ] in
a drum circle and it's like dude like
yeah I see the intensity and the feeling
but that ain't doing [ __ ] what you know
the [ __ ] that they were doing on [ __ ]
um Wall Street bets are like trying to
take down hedge funds and things like
that like now that's effective or that's
hurting certain things because it's
hurting their money hurting the money
that's all you got to do and something's
about financials that's all you got to
do is gonna hurt the money if you if
these companies are coming in and trying
to [ __ ] up your neighborhood [ __ ] those
companies up
figure out how to hurt their money
that's all not their feelings don't [ __ ]
with their field that doesn't do
anything companies don't have feelings
yeah they're called I'm gonna disagree
dude bongo drums are very effective
you just gotta tune them that's all
we're gonna fight the man
hear that what's that Rhythm it's like I
am now aware all these business people
are like oh no not the [ __ ] bongo
drums there's hippies
no but you're right man yeah it's
definitely going after the money for
sure is the way to go get the money and
but they're not educated on how to
attack how to fight like in business so
then they do the best that they can
which is go out into the streets and
show their anger but like that really
does absolutely do nothing they need
leaders out there I don't want to lead
man
well you know what
if we could just give this information
somehow but then at the end of the day
like the people that need to hear and do
something about it
um I don't even think
they're effectively thinking they don't
have internet well I think the people uh
but you know I think societies kept them
in the grind where your head is down
just like trying to make it through the
next day even though you're hearing it
you're not hearing it because you're
just trying to make it to the next day
and get the next check that's kind of
like I think that's exactly right
because it's like how do you have time
to study about the government when
you're too busy trying to [ __ ] feed
your family so it's like you're too busy
being your family
that's true that's true
quit being a lazy [ __ ] can you make that
just a clip on Instagram stop feeding
your family
[Music]
[Music]